sarah elle a erré bonjour vous êtes
secrétaire d'état en charge de la
jeunesse et du service national
universel décembre 2010 2017 françois
ruffin s'exprime à la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale vêtu d'un maillot
de football sanctions 1400 euros damende
novembre 2018 jean lassalle revers gilet
jaune au sein de l'hémicycle sanctions
1500 euros damende juillet 2022 rémy
rebeyrotte fait un salut nazi dans
l'hémicycle aucune sanction
pia il ya eu un geste extrêmement grave
un salut nazi c'est un geste extrêmement
grave choquant choquant condamnable et a
condamné maintenant qu'elle a été la
procédure il ya eu un geste il à une
convocation de la part de la présidente
de l'assemblée nationale il est une
enquête qui a été ouverte au sein de
l'assemblée nationale à la suite de
cette enquête la présidente de
l'assemblée nationale décide qu'il ya un
rappel à l'ordre un rappel à l'ordre ce
n'est pas une absence de sanction c'est
une fonction qui est lourde dans le
cadre de l'assemblée dans le cas de son
règlement maintenant mais lorsqu'on la
compare aux sanctions qui ont été
réalisés pour certains faits commis
durant la législature précédente on peut
s'interroger justement la question qui
se pose c'est est-ce que vous vous avez
eu accès au rapport d'enquêté aux
éléments complémentaires que la
présidente de l'assemblée nationale a eu
dans le cadre de ces échanges est dans
le cadre de la convocation du milieu du
député qui a commis cet acte moi je n'ai
pas eu ces informations là je n'ai pas
eu accès à ce rapport là maintenant est
ce qu'un rappel à l'ordre est un acte
est une sanction la réponse est oui
l'idée c'est de laisser imaginer qu'il
n'y a pas eu de sanctions ce n'est pas
le cas il y à une sanction c'est une
fonction importante est évidemment à
l'assemblée nationale le faisons parce
que parce que je suis une députée à la
base et bien c'est un lieu qu'il faut
protéger protéger de toutes les
outrances et protéger des dérapages
c'est pour ça que la sanction était
nécessaire et le député a présenté ses
excuses parce que oui c'est un acte
grave on va en parler justement de ce
qui se passe à l'assemblée nationale
l'examen du projet de loi en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat donné lieu à des passes
d'armes frôlant parfois la violence tout
au long de cette semaine je n'ai pas les
lister ce matin mais ses invectives ces
injures permanente n'ont pas lieu d'être
non au sein de l'assemblée nationale
quelle image cela renvoie pour les
spectateurs qui parfois peuvent voir ces
images ces menaces et le lieu de la
représentation du peuple de france c'est
un des lieux de plus les plus sacrés de
la république parce que on y construit
du consensus notre priorité des
priorités quand je dis nous c'est
normalement tous les députés tous les
députés les sénateurs quel que soit en
réalité leurs origines politiques ou
territoriale aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit
c'est un spectacle malheureusement
d'outrance d'abus d'excès qui ne fait
que parfois aller chercher cette petite
capsule vidéo pour aller sur twitter que
ce soit du côté parfois de l'extrême
droite ou que ce soit du côté de l'ex à
sembler nationale devenu un outil de
communication pour les députés
simplement c'est malheureux parce que on
réussit parfois aller chercher ce
consensus et notre volonté est
malheureusement comme hier soir encore
il y a des moments qui sont scénarisés
volontairement pour aller sur les
réseaux face à ça il faut rester moi je
crois très réaliste et très simple les
français sont témoins de ce qui se passe
à l'assemblée nationale nous nos jobs
notre mission c'est de faire que oui le
texte pouvoir d'achat abouti ca y est
allé chercher ses compromis alors oui on
fait on accompagne les travaux des
députés socialistes des députés l'ère
des députés de la majorité pour aller
construire ses réponses mais du
quotidien quand on voit le coût du
carburant quand on voit que parfois on
n'arrive pas à finir sa fin de mois
alors qu'on bosse et qu'on bosse au
maximum alors qu'on on peut transformer
ses rtt en salaire on peut aller on peut
aller chercher cette défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires parce que oui
quand on bosse on doit vivre dignement
dans notre pays ça c'est notre mission
ça c'est notre job par contre ceux qui
veulent chercher les buzz et les super
tweets et ben ça c'est leur
responsabilité
les français en sont tellement justement
on en parle et les invectives fusent les
débats patine malheureusement puisque le
texte est toujours débattu à l'assemblée
nationale les travaux autour du du plfr
se sont interrompus à nouveau cette nuit
est ce que vous craignez que la
recomposition du paysage politique
depuis les élections législatives
n'entraîne des difficultés importantes
dans la gestion du pays aujourd'hui on
parle de mesures d'urgence avec une
attente très forte des français
concernant leur pouvoir d'achat
moi je suis une députée est
fondamentalement j'ai la conviction
qu'on n'y arrivera pas que
ce qui se joue c'est le quotidien des
français c'est le prix du carburant
c'est la revalorisation des indices de
la fonction publique c'est la protection
des pensions de nos retraités parce
qu'ils ont travaillé toute leur vie
c'est permettre à ceux qui travaillent
eh bien oui d'avoir de l'argent
supplémentaire pour finir leurs fins de
mois et répondre à l'urgence que nous
vivons et à côté de ça on a voté il ya à
peine quelques jours la loi sanitaire et
on avait une sorte de nouvelle
démocratie se construire puisque il ya
des députés heller socialistes qui ont
expliqué en tribunes et je pense aux
députés bras en particulier des pieds
qui dit nous sommes dans un nouvel
exercice les français ont souhaité qu'on
soit le premier groupe de l'assemblée
mais qu'on n'ait pas de majorité absolue
les français ont souhaité le tpi en tout
cas c'est un souhait démocratique des
français à nous d'aller construire ce
consensus avec des députés et des
sénateurs qui cherchent et qui ont
l'obsession de ce cet intérêt général de
la réponse aux français et pas des
petites tactiques politiciennes ou de
buzz à deux fins franchement à deux
secondes qui ne font que la durée de vie
twitter et qui s'arrêtent et qui ne
transforme pas la vie des français donc
là ça ça moi je plutôt la conviction
qu'on y arrivera avec beaucoup de
sérieux avec beaucoup d'engagement
beaucoup d'acharnement mais les français
en ont besoin et nous on sera à leurs
côtés on parle beaucoup pouvoir d'achat
en ce moment on parle également de
sobriété énergétique depuis l'allocution
du président de la république le 14
juillet dernier il y à une circulaire
qui a été envoyé hier soir à l'ensemble
des membres du gouvernement est ce que
vous l'avez reçu circulaire dans
laquelle il avait deux bornes appelle
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
et leur administration à prendre des
mesures de sobriété énergétique
d'ampleur bien sûr bien sûr que nous
avons reçues et tu peux pas les mots
faire tu peux pas demander un effort aux
français saison si tu te les applis pas
à toi même la planète le climat notre
responsabilité même pour passer cet
hiver en particulier c'est une
responsabilité collective tous ceux qui
vous disent y'a qu'à faut qu'on mais
imandt il
ya plusieurs gestes aux coupes les
climatisations mon sort de la semaine de
canicule on fait attention aux
transports on passe des messages
extrêmement fort et extrêmement
ambitieux et ça c'est notre
responsabilité individuels moi j'ai
toujours cru que pour répondre aux
grands enjeux de notre temps il faut
l'engagement des entreprises il faut
l'engagement de l'état bien sûr il faut
une transformation de nos pratiques
quotidiennes il faut accompagner ceux
qui n'ont pas d'autre choix que
d'utiliser aujourd'hui malheureusement
soit bas du gasoil et du coup ça coûte
cher soit du fuel et ça coûte cher pour
rénover les maisons et pour moins
dépendre la meilleure des économies
c'est l'énergie qu'on n'a pas dépensé
voit bien au modem le modem je pose
cette question car il semble que vos
collègues d'horizon des envies de
prendre le large on l'a vu notamment
lors de votes qui se sont déroulés ce
week-end on était réuni hier avec
l'ensemble de mon groupe parlementaire
pourrait changer évidemment sur
l'actualité à l'assemblée nationale la
majorité elle est diverse va pas on va
on est absolument pas elle est diverse
mais pas diviser parce qu elle est unie
derrière un projet est uni derrière des
valeurs alors oui on a des histoires
différentes moi je viens du parti du
centre horizon vient plutôt de la droite
ensemble c'est un parcours complet
maintenant c'est quoi la différence
des histoires des actions parfois des
réponses des chemins mais les valeurs et
le cercle est commun alors oui moi je me
ravi que l'assemblée nationale et puis
soit aussi l'expression de cette
nouvelle méthode et parfois de vote qui
diffèrent mais le plus important c'est
de garder ce socle commun c'est les
valeurs du cac on a l'impression que
l'assemblée nationale est peut-être à
l'image du pays qui est fracturée en ce
moment cela me fait penser à cette
phrase prononcée par gérard collomb
lorsqu'il a dû quitter le ministère de
l'intérieur aujourd'hui envie
côte-à-côte je crains que demain une
vive face à face à ce sujet des
policiers sont régulièrement la cible de
violences on en a énormément parlé
encore la semaine dernière avec cette
attaque à l'encontre de trois policiers
à lyon policiers qui ont essuyé des
coups des jets de projectiles c'est
intolérable pour vous et comment
expliquer que cela continue d'être
reproduits au sein de notre société ses
attaques à l'encontre des forces de
l'ordre attaqué un policier
l'insulté ne pas respecter son uniforme
le violenter s'est attaqué la république
et les réponses doivent être d'une
fermeté sans nom parce qu'en réalité
c'est l'autorité qu'on ait brol mais
l'autorité de notre pays et donc c'est
le colloque avait pour justement
apporter je vous pose une question
simple et en même temps elle est
complexe résidentiel
elle est essentielle les réponses elles
sont dans la réponse judiciaire elle est
aussi dans l'éducation de nos enfants et
dont le retour des cadres et des regrets
ça ce sont des mots ce ne sont pas des
mots ce sont des transformations enfin
avec des preuves 2,7 milliards de moyens
supplémentaires pour nos forces de
l'ordre des moyens pour se protéger des
moyens aussi matérielles recrutement
humain plus de dix mille policiers et
gendarmes recruter le renforcement des
peines avec le ministre de la justice et
le garde des sceaux en mai quasiment
main dans la main avec gérald darmanin
cela va mieux entre de sa hâte au
prochain l'objectif il est il est le
même il est le même pour tout
gouvernement permettre la sécurité de
tous les français par tous quel que soit
son territoire et quel que soit son âge
parce que c'est la première des libertés
parce que sans sécurité et bien ou
n'avance pas alors quand moi je vois les
vidéos et quand je vois puisque vous
parlez du maire de lyon eh bien elles
sont intolérables il faut absolument pas
retourner la charge de la preuve ou de
je ne sais quoi
aller chercher du buzz sur des vidéos
alors même que ce sont des policiers qui
sont attaqués c'est gravissime vous
faites référence à qui en l'occurrence
je fais référence au maire de lizac te
ment exactement qui ne fait que
retourner un peu et créer une sorte de
buzz après une situation hyper grave des
policiers ont été agressés alors oui il
faut condamner condamné fermement la
justice est saisie et la réponse les
réponses seront données et j'espère
qu'elles seront un problème justement
avec les maires écologistes je vous pose
cette question car de nombreux élus
visiblement vous faites partie élus de
l'opposition parfois je le précise
pointe du doigt le laxisme de ses mains
en matière de sécurité la sécurité ne
doit pas être un sujet idéologique
fondamentalement ne doit pas être
incités à ce sujet des logiques la
sécurité et 1 3 il faut l'accompagner
par contre on peut dire il ya qu'à
recruter des policiers nous en recrutons
nous en formons et c'est ma majorité qui
redonne des moyens par contre pour
répondre à cette sécurité il faudrait il
faut que ce soit dur de continuer ça
veut dire qu'il faut oui que dès que des
maires acceptent de mettre en place de
la vidéoprotection et la
vidéosurveillance il faut accompagner
les polices municipales et leur donner
les moyens ben oui de s'armer avec des
armes létales ou non létales ce sont des
débats locaux mais c'est nécessaire
donner les moyens aussi d'élargir le
temps et les interactions entre les
polices municipales et les polices
nationales mais s'il ya des deux
logiques et c'est le cas dans un certain
nombre de communes et ça a été le cas
chez moi à nantes eh bien on retarde
mais qui paye au bout qui paye les
conséquences de cette idéologie et bien
les nantais où les grenoblois et parfois
les lyonnais vous êtes rattaché au
ministère de l'éducation nationale mais
également à celui des armes et pourquoi
la jeunesse est-elle désormais en partie
sous la tutelle des armes et que faut-il
comprendre c'est une chance c'est une
chance pour notre pays que toutes les
forces en présence toutes les forces
vives de notre pays que ce soit nos
armes et les enseignants ou encore plus
largement ceux qui éduque donc le monde
de l'éducation populaire et bien soit
unie autour de nous de nos jeunes de nos
jeunes d'adolescents vous savez que j'ai
le déploiement du service national
universel il sera généralisé justement
d'ici la fin du quinquennat il sera
accompagné vers cette généralisation et
il faut réunir autour toutes les forces
vives vous savez que vous n'aurez pas
d'armé c'est vraiment à ma question est
ce qu'il sera généralisée d'ici la fin
du quinquennat long car ce qui est la
nôtre c'est évidemment de généraliser et
d'universaliser l'accès du service
national mais recèle pourquoi parce que
en réalité il ya trop de quel âge entre
15 et 17 entre 15 et 17 ans pour toute
une génération mais c'est quoi le
service de son adversaire pour ceux qui
nous écoutent c'est le fait que entre 15
et 17 ans eh bien on est le devoir de
porter un uniforme de lever un drapeau
de faire nation c'est à dire de créer la
rencontre entre des jeunes qui viennent
de territoires différents deux mondes
différents de découvrir à quel point
notre pays est beau parce qu'on a une
rencontre avec la république ça veut
dire avec nos élus avec les préfets avec
les pompiers permettre à ces jeunes de
prendre conscience qu'il a un devoir
vis-à-vis de notre pays celui de
s'engager mais aussi de lui faire
découvrir tous ses droits et tout un
champ d'orientation possible un jeune
qui s'engage c'est un jeune qui rejoint
nos réserves civile militaire
gendarmerie c'est un jeune qui rejoint
des associations la spa les restos du
coeur mais également toutes les
associations de tutorat ou de mentorat
de solidarité c'est un jeune qui va
faire un service civique et qui se
rencontrent que oui un peuple fort un
peuple résilient c'est un peu piqué unis
qui se connaît mais qui fait bloc et
aujourd'hui pour faire bloc et bien il
faut un goût de l'effort un goût de la
découverte mais surtout beaucoup de
confiance en la vie on ira vers la
généralisation pour l'ensemble des
jeunes de 15 à 17 ans du service
national gilles boeuf dans combien de
dossiers le même objectif c'est un moi
c'est en deux temps quinze jours de
séjour de cohésion où on a le droit de
quitter son département d'être
accompagnés sans différence parce qu'il
n'ya pas assez pris en charge par la
solidarité nationale où qu'on soit fils
en réalité de cadres ou d'ouvriers on a
la même chance les mêmes droits et
ensuite on a des devoir arpenter de
retrouver une cohésion nationale lors de
la crise sanitaire vous aviez lancé
l'initiative je veux aider justement
afin de permettre à des jeunes de
s'engager bénévolement dans une dans une
ou dans des associations après les
incendies qui ont ravagé la gironde est
ce que vous allez relancer cette
opération il se trouve que face aux
catastrophes que nous vivons oui moi
j'aurai à j'appelle vraiment tous ceux
qui souhaitent participer demain aux
réponses au soutien pour reboiser pour
replanter des arbres pour remettre
finalement notre paysage comme on les
aime et retrouver ses paysages français
que nous aimons et gironde a en
particulier de rejoindre la réserve je
veux aider point gouv.fr parce que des
missions seront lancés et
j'accompagnerai des jeunes en service
civique et demain des missions d'intérêt
général de ces jeunes qui font le
service national universel pour
accompagner notre patrimoine allez le
rénover leur mettre en beauté et surtout
replanter nos frais donc la fin de
reprendre tes les forêts afin bd par
exemple les sinistrés également dans
l'eau dans nos communes où allez vous
êtes sur place quand le quand la
sécurité le permettra parce
qu'aujourd'hui le feu vous savez il est
encore il est encore là est la priorité
et l'accompagnement et d'ailleurs je
rappelle un soutien énorme à nos
pompiers qui viennent de partout sur le
territoire parce que oui face à ces
drames eh bien il faut qu'on soit plus
que jamais solidaire c'est beaucoup ça